so let's go to this clip on the pbd
podcast and I want to stick with this
word this term that bosim called Adam
out on that's exactly what you're saying
they're just like poor people killing
each other and we're just like there
watching them I'm I'm sorry that dude I
like you but seriously your undertone is
racist from the beginning until
the end you are looking at those people
are lesser people who have made bad
choices and because they are poor they
are okay to be like they've destroyed so
much have you seen the footage the
recent footage it's crazy mosques it's
just bombing MOS bombing buildings
Zionism is racism now just replace the
term Arab with Jew imagine that he's an
Arab he's an you know just get rid of
him Zionism is a racist ideology and our
friend Patrick he's Armenian Assyrian
also and we see how they're treated
those Rel extremist they don't want us
basically they they tell us every time
they we don't want to get out of Israel